it
's dem Tim Tim Tim Tim Tim Tim wir sind
in einer Küche die ihr noch nicht kennt
danke schön dass wir die Ehre dass wir
drehen dürfen
also falls ihr eure lieblings Kochshows
wieder erkennt wir sind die Lieblings
Kochshow absolut wir machen Cocktails
komm schon
herzlich willkommen
eingeladen denn
wir
drehen heute wieder drei cockt
sind
Gruppe
in der du nicht da bist
du zusammen sprechen
also Leute heute ist es was ganz
besonderes nach fünf Jahren kann ich das
erste mal sagen
ist gespannt und jetzt alle die hier ist
gespannt was habt ihr gesprochen in der
Gruppe wo ich nicht drin
von unserem Freund sausam Komfort ich
liebe das das Haus ankommt ich habe
gesagt
thank you an dieser Stelle ich habe vor
dem Kompott auf dem Ems getestet ich
habe es für uns sorry
ja ich glaube Taylor Swift gesehen ist
herzlichen Dank die ihr wählen
korrekt dicker auf den Ems gab es einen
Soko schon mal ein
Song noch nicht aber ich würde gerne
noch nicht aber ich würde gerne ich habe
mich ein neues Skript ich habe keins
also das ist ein Whiskey Likör und den
kann man super zum Cocktail Mission
verwenden man kann den auch als shot
trinken aber wir machen
heute bringt meine reiznasistentin die
drei Community vorbereitet hat WoW
thank you Liner
oh guck mal diese Eiswürfel sehen aber
toll also
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
machen kann
ja und da ist auch Ginger Bier drin
Limette und Minze
reinkommen
dann zieht die kassieren das rüber so
nee nee sorry ich habe ein Rabatt 25
355 jetzt erst wenn wir natürlich unsere
eigen
natürlich jetzt habt ihr einen
Geschmacksexplosion bekommen
und jetzt verrate ich euch das Thema für
heute und deswegen bin ich so happy dass
Freddy im Weihnachtsmannkostüm gekommen
ist nein Quatsch habe ich das schon
vorher gesagt wir tun
okay
also ich verrate euch jetzt das Thema
für heute der Weihnachtsmann hat keine
Lust mehr auf mich und Kekse oh langsam
was für Zufall dass ich genau
so mach ihm ein Cocktail damit der Bock
hat meiner Geschenke zu verteilen
wir gehen jetzt einkaufen
mein Gott
wer möchte anfangen
[Gelächter]
Sprudelwasser
Kinderpunsch
Ginger Bier das sieht wirklich aus der
Weihnachtsmann trinken würde oder
Vitaminwasser und jetzt kommen erstmal
die Frucht eine Melone
[Musik]
Kerzen und Strohhalme
letztes Mal benutzt
ich habe mich nicht weiter und Tüten wer
wird sein als nächstes willkommen ich
habe Kakao gut steht auf der Couch auf
eine Cover
Kaffee habe ich noch mal Kaffee weil du
weißt ja niemanden
gedacht habe gekauft
[Gelächter]
wow für mich auch immer das sind gemeine
Mandeln keine Plätzchen na ja
es war Koala Miller dann habe ich noch
hier dabei ein bisschen Butter
Spekulatius natürlich von der Bäckerei
frische aber ich habe von Feuerzeug
dabei Feuer
gleich ja
[Musik]
damit ihr in weihnachtliche Stimmung
kommt mit Zuckerstange für euch und
natürlich benutzt jeder von denen auch
[Musik]
so Leute komm her komm komm dran komm
dran an die Mutti hat gar nicht zu
meinen Farben
und damit ich hasse diese Teil
mögen die durch spielen
[Musik]
ist eine wunderbare Sache
oh nee wie macht man das denn auf halt
das nicht in die Kamera
[Musik]
das ist doch nicht schlimm
wenn du
[Musik]
wenn du da bist dieses
wenn du da dieses Metall ab machst diese
diabete dann geht es doch auch nicht
direkt in die Luft
[Musik]
ich habe doch nicht so eine Angst was
ist denn los mit euch ich drücke einfach
richtig schnell runter jetzt ja
[Gelächter]
nichts passiert
wofür das ist
[Musik]
ich hoffe ihr schreibt zu Hause mit für
dieses schöne Rezept
das ist sehr sehr viel
coolen will
[Musik]
also ich habe aufgegeben zu messen ich
mache jetzt free hand
okay willkommen bei meiner cocktailshow
keine
Mixer haben
noch nie im Mix in unserer seit fünf
Jahren stehen im Cocktail Format
probieren ich habe das hier gekauft weil
da steht ohne Koffein und ich trinke
keinen Koffein aber es soll
ein Problem
enthält einen halben Liter Motivation
mit vollem Geschmack
okay jetzt fange ich an meinen Cocktail
zu mixen
[Gelächter]
auf dem Heimweg falsch abgebogen sie
kommt noch mal den Start
weniger schon
[Gelächter]
ich habe wieder so Angst
jetzt nehme ich Zuschlags auf saufen
Camper
für den kleinen benutzt für Ahornsirup
[Musik]
das wollte ich so
einfach die Farbe eliminiert
aus
ist das
okay ich habe ihn
[Musik]
ich habe ihn aber ich kann nicht mehr
davon machen weil ich nicht weiß wie
viel ich von was rein gemacht habe und
was überhaupt drin ist
starten
theoretisch wenn ich jetzt
das hier benutze
und dann kommt ein
kleines
[Musik]
das macht
ich brauche die Herdplatte
doch sorry
aber ich habe trotzdem Spaß
[Musik]
guten Morgen Internet
hallo
ich weiß es nicht
Vorsicht Vanessas könnte sein das heißt
Induktion das ist ähm hä wie wird das
dann warm
[Gelächter]
funktioniert
erklärt werden kann das an diesem
Schaubild ganz oben sieht man den Topf
die Balken sind die Herdplatte und unter
der Herdplatte kann man die Spule sehen
die das Magnetfeld erzeugt oder wie
sagen magic
hahaha
Hammer
manipulieren nur deine Balls von meinem
Freund
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
so ich will hier mein machen
er Kanal macht ne oh wie heißt der denn
lausche
Melone
sonst machen
noch eine Melone klar kein Problem ist
übrigens Lebensmittel geeignet falls ihr
euch fragt ne natürlich habe ich mich
nicht gefragt hey warte mal kurz
so in meine Tüte kommt jetzt auch noch
mal Glitzer
macht man das so
ein schönes Lagerfeuer aber pass auf
nicht zu genau
[Gelächter]
tschüss
[Musik]
oh mein Gott dieser Typ
aufgefallen ist das im Bild Freddy hast
du deine Augen also ich habe keine
Brille
[Musik]
also erstmal Leute alle amazing dieses
Mal ihr habt euch ganz besonders Mühe
gegeben und dafür verdienen wir einen
kräftigen Applaus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
endlich guckt jemand zu
oh Spongebob bei south
also ich würde sagen Freddy fängt an
weil sie ein schmilz Weg ja
einen leckeren äh bisschen Kaffee Kakao
Mix zu nehmen weil ich wusste dass ich
anfangen wie immer und wenn man es ein
bisschen Kaffee kriegt richtig hier
durch so eine Seite dass dieser das war
glaube ich schon das beste da gibt's nur
noch besser ja dann habe ich nur eine
Kerze angemacht für den Weihnachtsmann
weil der erste Advent ist vielleicht
schon war frohe Weihnachten dann habe
ich das so geschmückt wie so ein
Tannenbaum Zimt ein bisschen rüber und
dann kann man das jetzt so trinken das
lecker so wisst die Kakao schokomil
unten sowas kühles auf das warm ist noch
da kann man so den Sporen hochziehen und
du musst seine wunderbare
weihnachtsmannschaft mit kleinen
damit der Weihnachtsmann noch weiß wohin
guckt
oh süß aber das weil die Meister werden
ach so das ist nicht hart von Milch
okay
dies ist
Ingwer short weil ihr wisst wenn man so
viel in der Kälte unterwegs ist wieder
Weihnachtsmann ist man 100% erkältet und
da braucht er halt ein bisschen was was
sie Bakterien abtötet in seinem machen
deswegen ein bisschen Ingwer bisschen
Zitrone Zitrone vom Vitamin C außerdem
haben wir hier die ne die ähm
Zusammenführung aus süß und ein bisschen
sauer und bitter ne und das ist ja auch
das wo der Weihnachtsmann bei euch zu
Hause unterscheidet da dir das ganze
Jahr lieb und süß und nett und Geschenke
und da war
die Kinder waren die nicht so die
Hausaufgaben gemacht haben und sich
trotzdem scheiße aus dem Arsch gezogen
und dunkel draußen so wie das Leben der
fibrisst wenn man manchmal gut manchmal
nicht ja und da könnt ihr jetzt auch
einfach mal probieren so in der finalen
Form habe ich jetzt noch nicht probiert
ne okay
Vanessa lange nicht mehr gekotzt bei den
Folgen von dir also erstmals
[Gelächter]
also ich bin nicht überrascht oder sowas
natürlich
aber umso Mehrzahl dann kommt halt umso
besser
meine Cocktails geht okay machen wir
weiter mit meinem Cocktail also ich habe
den Sack das Weihnachtsmanns
nachbestellt
in meiner Erinnerung
[Gelächter]
gekommen weil auch das eine Getränk was
ich gekauft habe ist Galaxy und wo
fliegt der Weihnachtsmann durch die
Galaxy
im Universum also der ist im All also
was für Marvel was hast du gesehen was
ein Weihnachtsmann Alter
Sterne und
das ist so diese zauberspur die auf der
Welt hinterher das verstehe ich ja und
na gut aber dann sind meine kleinen
Planeten sind jetzt eigentlich
aber ich habe einen großen Planet ich
habe Melonen Planeten das nicht zufällig
vielleicht von einem Schneemann die
einzelnen Teile die bevor sie
zusammengebaut werden ja das sind
Schneekugeln weil wenn ihr nebeneinander
gesessen hättet in der Schule ne
Paris nicht zufällig so ich finde sie
hat gut vorgetragen und es ist halt
etwas aufpus drin weil der hat ja viel
zu tun in der Nacht und natürlich sagt
dann kommt weiter damit dass sie ein
bisschen wohlfühlt ein bisschen so Wärme
so immer noch der Weihnachtsabend Wärme
und jeder trinkt ja gerne an Weihnachten
schönes einen schönen Cocktail schönes
warum sind wir so gut
ach so ach und das wichtigste also mein
Grundgedanke war eigentlich das ist halt
ein to-go welcher ist bei dir muss er
sich ein bisschen hinsetzen und kurz
chillen bei dir kann also schnell
snacken und das ist so wenig weißt du
und dann hat er wieder ab und bei mir
kann er sagen so die nehme ich mir jetzt
für den Schlitten dann sagen wir jetzt
unsere Bewertung okay bei drei sagen wir
den Namen den wir glauben wir gewonnen
hat 1 2 3 4 5
Vanessa ich habe alle gesagt was ist das
cool und hast keine Kelly sagen
also im Prinzip du hast für uns alle
Punkte gegeben süß das heißt 1:1 so dann
habe ich dir Punkt gegeben das heißt 121
und Caddy mir das heißt zwei zwei eins
so wir machen schnick schnack schnuck
i
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
gib mir Moment
[Musik]
aber eigentlich muss man dieses mal
sagen wann wir alle richtig gut du
darfst nicht
ich liebe deine Schmerzen ich hoffe wir
konnten euch tolle Inspirationen geben
was ihr mit dem southern Comfort so
alles an Cocktails machen können und ich
bin sehr froh dass alle unsere Cocktails
geschmeckt haben weil es hätte mich sehr
traurig gemacht wenn die jetzt dazu
geschaut hätten alle irgendwie
zusammengemisch deswegen sehr verstört
und überrascht genau dann geben wir uns
mehr hey hey
gib uns Geld dann geben wir uns müde
gibt und Geld dann geben wir auch am
Arsch
[Gelächter]
tschüss tschüss aus dann kommt fort
können wir das noch mal üben einfach
besser so dann komm fort sausenkomfort
[Musik]